you
[Music]
veteran journalist robin Leach has died
he was 76 years old so I'm the man
that's known for champagne wishes and
caviar dreams leach famously known for
hosting the show lifestyles of the rich
and famous from 1984 to 1995 died Friday
in Las Vegas just days before his 77th
birthday before his big break the
journalists help launch our own
syndicated show Entertainment Tonight in
1981 welcome to our opening night the
premiere edition of Entertainment
Tonight the celebrity reporter who later
joined the Las Vegas review-journal in
2016
had reportedly been hospitalized since
last November after suffering a stroke
in Cabo San Lucas on Monday leech
suffered another stroke and was admitted
to hospice care until his death panel
average the lifestyle would you lead if
you were the richest man on earth
the TV host is survived by his sons who
shared a statement with ET quote
everyone's support and love over the
past almost one year has been incredible
and we are so grateful
[Music]
you